[Music]
[Applause]
we spend hours at salons and barbers but
there's more to a haircut than meets the
eye why do we cut our hair what if we
all stopped cutting our hair what would
this do to the hair industry this is
what if and here's what would happen if
everyone stopped cutting their hair
let's start at the root of this you have
about five million hair follicles all
over your body our visible hair is the
hair shaft sticking out from the skin
with the root sunk in a follicle under
the surface of the skin except for a
small number of growing cells at the
root base human hair is dead tissue
composed of keratin and other proteins
cells rapidly divide at the base of the
follicle they push upward harden undergo
pigmentation and then you have hair so
why do we cut our hair cutting hair can
be about self-expression but some people
will cut their hair if they suffer
trauma like the loss of a loved one a
relationship or even failing health
according to psychologists making
changes to your appearance provides a
soothing feeling because the results are
obvious and immediate it can mark a
beginning of significant life changes in
the 1920s when women started chopping
their hair short the societal reactions
were mixed before this long hair was
considered feminine families were
embarrassed by their daughters who
decided to get the stylish bob hair
cotton some men started shunning these
boyish women but what if we all stopped
cutting our hair would this new world
have social cliques like growers and non
growers would we make comparisons to
other people based on how long their
hair is would having beautiful long
flowing hair be associated with
fertility and good health
the popularity of long hair contests
would explode what about strong hair
competitions will we all be tuning in to
the International hair freezing
competition and what would it mean for
people who are losing their hair those
not able to grow lengthy hair would
likely become more self-conscious and
feel inadequate hair loss might be a
sign of mortality and that would be very
distressing and what about people who
are already bald and shave their heads
in this crazy new world of hair growers
this isn't an option anymore so you're
stuck with whatever patches of hair you
have or don't have and what would this
do to the hair industry salons would now
focus on hair styling coloring and other
hair related services the upkeep would
be phenomenal hair accessories would
become even more popular because people
will look for creative ways to express
themselves gels sculpting creams and
other products would help you deal with
this ever-growing mound of hair and
there may be hope for our balding
friends after all wigs the wig industry
could step up and help them out offering
artificial hair solutions now everyone's
included or would wig wearers be
considered imposters those with super
curly hair could run into some dangerous
situations getting their hair cut and
anything and everything let me just duck
out of here for a second to bring you a
public service announcement from our
sponsor manscape calm manscaped provides
the best in men's grooming and hygiene
made from only the best products and
ingredients for the modern man and
manscaped has changed the grooming game
with their perfect package 3.0
essentials kit this complete package
comes with the new and improved
lawnmower 3.0 a water-resistant cordless
body trimmer their advanced skin safe
technology and cutting-edge ceramic
blade
make your trimming Nick free and the kit
includes an anti chafing deodorant and
moisturizer to help you feel and smell
your best subscribers to the perfect
package 3.0 kit get a new replacement
blade delivered to their door every
three months and for a limited time you
get not one but two free gifts this shed
travel bag and the patented high
performance anti chafing manscaped boxer
briefs get 20% off now when you go to
manscaped calm and use the promo code
what if okay let's do some quick math
hair grows an average of one centimeter
each month multiply that by 12 months
and then by another 6 years that's
almost a meter so over the span of 6
years and a meter of hair can you
imagine the unlimited range of hairstyle
options whether you like it or not
you would have to deal with it being
part of you I suppose you could always
tie it back into a ponytail maybe this
will be another social class the
laid-back ponytail people who knows new
medical practices could grow in
popularity like hair analysis hair can
grow on you for two to six years before
falling out during that time your hair
shaft absorbs chemicals from any drugs
you take it also contains sweat your
body's natural oils and any toxins
around you
a single strand of hair can give a lot
of information hair analysis uses
special techniques to look at your hair
under a microscope the results can show
details about your health and habits and
help you pinpoint needed lifestyle
changes we would also encounter a series
of new problems on average people lose
between 50 to 100 hairs a day so that
hair will be everywhere imagine what our
shower drains would look like we could
start new clothing or carpet making
companies with all this surplus hair
hair as a form of expression is very
important there's no denying the amount
of creativity we would see with hair
styles but do you think people could go
their whole lives without cutting their
hair we are so focused on appearance
especially on social media would there
eventually be a haircutting revolution
somewhere on the dark web an underground
community of people who have short hair
what if they had to spend their whole
life underground well that's a story for
another what if